good health to mejía with the
most outstanding news of the day today the
governor of nevada sticks is the one who will
detail the next steps that will be
taken regarding the capacities of
public meetings and restrictions on
businesses the report is scheduled
at 4 in the  late to a week before
the restrictions that were
implemented more than two months ago expire to
listen to the governor's announcement
live you can visit our page or
social networks of egin now or in Spanish
the coronavirus vaccine clinic
in downtown
las vegas convention is already operating as
normal after a day of long lines
caused by a flaw in its
registration system that forced workers
to manually register
patients many of these people
said that even though some
had appointments they waited in  lines for
up to four hours
and the food bank missed the announcement
that it has extended its service dates
at its center.  or distribution at the
eastside cannery hotel the site
is currently open fridays from
9 am until sold out
free square official reservations
confirmed that the site will remain
open every friday until
february 26 we have a list of the
distribution sites on our website
and after two years of restrictions and
investigations
boeing the
world's largest commercial aircraft manufacturer received
the green light at the end of last year to
return to operating its 737 mex models today
three of these aircraft operated under
united airlines are scheduled to
land at the airport they want me
this afternoon the 737 max would have been
immobilized almost two years ago after
several accidents in indonesia and
ethiopia which claimed the lives of 346
people
and now a look at the
weather forecast we have a nice  Thursday
ahead with sunny skies
today's high 70 degrees then the clouds arrive
for tonight  and a slight chance of
some downpours early in the
morning friday have a happy thursday and take care of yourself
i'm héctor mejía that was your
brief disney newscast in spanish
[Music]